Hello again, this is Dr. Cavacaner, this is part four of our
beading credit line series of just
introduction to Lyme disease.
Hopefully you've been following along, you've found out that
what a cute stage line is and how to treat that and that it only is.
A window of opportunity to deal with it,
a credit stage line is a window as well.
I didn't talk about that but it is a window as well.
But some people can be in that window for their own life
in the chronic stage where you can successfully
knock it down and treat it with different immune stimulants.
So, this is a complete dissertation on autoimmune disease obviously,
but you're going to get a year full today.
But all these things are TH1 stimulants that we're going to talk about.
So, the third stage of
chronic Lyme disease that we mainly see in our office is in the autoimmune stage.
So, this phase three or autoimmune phase of chronic Lyme disease
is the most debilitated.
So, here's some pictures that we can spend some time on.
So, an autoimmune disease is a disease that
where your immune system attacks your self tissue and we're going to explain that in detail.
But it's really named after the main body part that brought that person in the office.
So, the person goes into their doctor with thyroid symptoms
and the doctor runs a complete thyroid panel and finds out that they have hypothyroid.
But the doctor was a great doctor and he also ran antibody tests on that patient
to see if they were actually making antibodies against their own thyroid gland.
And sure enough, they have thyroid antibodies in their blood.
So, that means their immune system, specifically their TH2 side of their immune system,
is created antibodies against their thyroid gland.
So, then the patient is, if they have hypothyroid and antibodies to their thyroid gland,
they are given a label called Hashimoto's Disease.
Hashimoto's Disease is, by definition, an autoimmune hypothyroid condition.
So, then the patient goes, oh, what does that mean?
And the doctor will typically, almost always say,
we don't know how it starts. Here's your Syntheroid, start taking that.
Well, what good was it for the person to know they have Hashimoto's Disease in autoimmune attack on their thyroid,
versus knowing that they just are believing that they just had a hypothyroid
because there's multiple different types of low thyroid as we're discussing right now.
And only one of them is Hashimoto's, you're developing, you have developed antibodies against your thyroid.
Well, in the medical world, there really is no benefit because they don't treat it.
They don't treat Hashimoto's any different than they treat hypothyroid.
Better fact, if you ask most doctors, what's the difference between Hashimoto's hypothyroid and hypothyroid,
they'd say, well, really nothing from a treatment perspective because they don't do anything different.
You're still just given thyroid medication.
Well, that is not adequate for us.
So, what is our motto? What has always been my motto?
And my clinic ever stopped asking, why?
So, why do I have Hashimoto's?
Unfortunately, if you ask even the greatest intercranologist, why do I have Hashimoto's?
They will most likely say, it is an idiopathic disease, which is Latin for, we don't know.
That's really what it's Latin for.
Maybe you could say it's Latin for.
I'm an idiot, don't ask me any more questions.
So, an autoimmune disease is named after the made tissue of destruction where you've created antibodies.
However, it doesn't tell us why you created antibodies against that disease.
There's a reason in Hashimoto's that you have created antibodies against your thyroid.
And you don't want to know what the reason is, the only reason that your body would create antibodies against your old tissue, regardless of whether it's your thyroid tissue,
whether it's your motor neurons in MS, the nylon sheet of the motor neurons, whether it's the neurons in ALS, whether it's the joint capsules in rheumatoid arthritis, whether it's the fatty layer of the skin in a psoriasis, whether it's the skin layer in rosacea,
whether it's whatever the named autoimmune system is.
The autoimmune disease is named after the tissue of greatest destruction where you have antibodies created against that tissue.
There was always, always, always, always in an antigen, in or near that tissue that created this immune response.
So, I have to explain this to you.
So, this is ebutology 101.
You have two major sides of your immune response.
You have your TH water response and your TH2 response.
Your TH water response is your killer cells.
They are the marine core.
They are the marine core with machine guns ready to kill whatever it's supposed to do.
They are just biting at the bullet, looking for something to kill.
Now, normally they're in balance and normally they're not firing very high.
But your body is making kids or cells on a daily basis.
Your body is exposed to virus and bacteria on a daily basis.
You can't eat food, you can't breathe in our environment and not be exposed to some pathogen.
So, you need healthy immune response, that is a healthy TH water response.
So, normally you're in this balance, but every day you have this little blip you could say of a TH water response.
It kills off that virus and it goes back into balance.
And then it blips up again and kills off that virus and it goes back into balance.
And it blips up and kills off that bacteria.
Oh, and it blips up and kills that little cancer cell that's growing in your liver, so no, that's gone.
It blips up and kills this and that.
That is a normal healthy immune response.
That's not an autoimmune disease yet.
That's an immune response.
So, normally there's a blip balance and the TH water fires initially.
That's your initial response to kill any pathogen.
Got it?
Super important.
What's in that TH water response and that TH2 response?
Well, the TH water response contains a whole bunch of different cytokines and chemokines.
And white blood cells and macrophages and killer cells, different types to kill different things.
So, they are circulating through your blood, looking for enemies.
The TH2 response is different.
It contains different cytokines and different chemokines.
But the main purpose of this TH2 or B cell response is to make antibodies.
So, where the TH1 response is to kill things, the TH2 response is to make antibodies.
So, if you could think of it in a cartoon type format.
The TH1 response are the machine gun, touting marine core.
The TH1 response is the machine gun, touting marine core.
The TH2 response is the FBI, the spies, the behind the scenes.
We're looking for the enemy.
We're going to go in, covertly look for the enemy and we're going to tag it with antibodies.
So, we're going to make antibodies against that which the TH1 side was trying to kill.
So, that the TH1 side comes in again, they'll be able to kill it.
Get it?
So, normally during a disease process you have a hyper-TH1 response, a hyper-TH2 response, a hyper-TH1 response, and you go back to health.
So, in a response for your, for any pathogen, let's use Lyme disease, Boralia, in this example.
You're exposed to the pathogen, you're exposed to that flu, you're exposed to that Boralia immediately.
So, goes into your body, you get a rash, whatever.
So, it's in your body, it's infected your bloodstream, the Boralia circulates from the bloodstream.
As soon as it's at a pathogenetic type of height in its disease, your immune system will fire a response.
So, that response is a TH1 response, so you get this hyper-TH1 response.
It's firey this response, and all these different killer cells are going out into the blood.
Looking for the enemy, we're going to kill it, we're going to kill it, we're going to kill it, we're going to kill it.
So, it's out there to destroy the enemy.
And if it destroys it, it knocks it down, then it goes back into balance and we have victory.
But usually, with a virulent bacteria like Boralia, it can't kill it very easy.
So, it's firey this TH1 response.
In the longer time that it can't kill it, you will fire more and greater quantity, more of these cytokines,
kibokines, white blood cells, macrophages.
So, you get this hyper-TH1 response.
This is when the person now, they move from immediately after the exposure to the next day.
They feel sick, they got a fever, they're in bed, what's wrong with me?
Give me some tea and lemon juice and honey, I'm sick, I must have the flu.
Oh, they're got diarrhea, they got to throw it up, whatever the disease process is taking them down.
So, that is a normal TH1 response, your body is trying to kill a disease.
Now, in an autoimmune disease, you have this hyper-TH1 response, followed by a TH2 response,
that is still not able to find the disease.
So, really the spider should have titled it differently.
In a normal immune response, you'll have a hyper-TH1 response, and then followed by a TH2 response also.
So, your TH2 response will follow anywhere between 24 to 72 hours later.
So, your marine core are out there in the field trying to kill this pathogen.
And for one, two, three, four days, and if it can't adequately kill the pathogen, what your body does is it pulls the marine core off.
It says, all right, get out of here, you don't even know what you're doing here, you can't find this guy.
Let's get the FBI in there to locate who this is.
So, the FBI, the TH2-B cell response, that fires all those cytokines and kibokines enter the area, and they're looking for the enemy.
Where are they? Where are they? Where are they? Oh, there they are.
And it makes an antibody against the enemy.
So, you make an antibody against the pathogen.
It's called an antigen now.
So, an antigen is anything that the immune system initially fired against.
So, in this case, Lyme disease, you make an antibody against Lyme disease.
It tags the Lyme Borrelia, and then you fire again a TH1 response, and the TH1 response goes, wow, oh, there you are.
I can see it. There, I can see it perfectly.
It's tagged with that fluorescent tape, and we could kill it.
That's a normal response, and you get healthy.
So, this is where, if you're not autoimmune yet, taking an eggination cancer claw and vitamin C and such can be very helpful.
But in an autoimmune disease, a person has fired this TH1, TH2, TH1 response multiple times.
So, we've gone weeks, months, maybe years of firing this TH1, TH2, TH1 response.
And the reason an autoimmune disease occurs is that when the TH2 response fires, it can't find the enemy.
So, remember, in adorable immune response, the TH1 response fires.
If it can't kill it, it's a really nasty virus or bacteria, it fires hyperfires.
That's when you get a fever and you feel sick.
It's still can't kill it after a couple days, it suppresses, and your TH2 response fires.
It goes in there, it tags the enemy, it suppresses, the TH1 response fires, it kills the enemy.
Everything goes back to normal, everything goes back to balance, you go back to work.
In an autoimmune disease, same thing happens.
TH1 response fires, it can't kill it.
Hyperfires, you feel sick.
TH2 response fires, TH1 suppresses.
TH2 response goes in to find the enemies, but they're not there.
Hids this what happens with Lyme disease.
Now, this could happen if they're not there, and it just suppresses in your TH1 response fires.
And this goes on through cycles, but at some point in time, with every person with an autoimmune disorder, this cycle happened.
And at some point in time, when the TH2 response fired, it couldn't find the enemy.
And it knew it was right around that thyroid gland.
Or it knew it was in the brain, and it knew it was near those neurons.
So it started creating antibodies to those neurons, to those glial cells that are covering the neuron that is called the mild and sheath.
Started to create antibodies to the astrocytes, started creating antibodies to the thyroid cells, started creating antibodies to your own fat cells,
to your own skin cells, to your own liver cells.
So an autoimmune disease is when you've reached that point.
When your TH2 response started creating antibodies to your old cells by definition, you have an autoimmune disease.
Got that?
Let's review.
Read up, what is an autoimmune disease?
Well, it's when my body is killing my own tissue.
Well, that's to find that. It's really not.
It's when my TH1 side, or my TH2 side, is hyperadfiring and killing my own tissue.
Because at one point in time, there was a pathogen there in that area that my TH2 side could not fire.
So it started to create antibodies against my old cells.
Hence, this is why.
Wait a person has an autoimmune disease of whatever.
I had radodes when I was a child and I had these rashes on my face, this rosacea autoimmune disease and radodes in my arms.
And now I have lupus.
I had thyroid issues.
You know, when I've had them for years and now I have rheumatoid arthritis.
Because the antigen was never found, was never dealt with.
You only treated the symptoms.
And pretty soon, as the antigen migrated to other areas, you actually created antibodies against tissue where it migrated to.
Got this? I know this is kind of confusing if you've never heard this before.
But an autoimmune disease is when a person is stuck in a hyper dominant TH1 or a hyper dominant TH2 response because it continues to fire against self tissue.
And why? Because there was an antigen there at one point in time and it's hiding in the cells.
So with autoimmune Lyme, the Lyme disease entered the person's body.
It was in the acute phase.
It entered the person's cells inside the cells. It moved into the chronic phase.
When you fire a TH1, TH2 response over time, back and forth, back and forth.
And the TH2 response is unable to find the antigen.
It can start creating antibodies against your old tissue.
That is the autoimmune phase.
This three of chronic Lyme is when your body is making antibodies against your old tissue that every time your immune system fires, you're destroying your old tissue.
That's why in a TH1 dominant patients, people, whether it's Lyme or whatever, TH dominant autoimmune patients cannot take TH1 stimulants.
You are just arming the side of your immune system that is killing your old cells.
You can't take an egg, an egg, an egg, an egg, an egg, an egg, an egg, an egg, an egg, an egg, an egg, an egg, an egg, an egg.
So you have to find alternate ways to treat the disease.
And this is where many, many, many chronic Lyme sufferers are.
They don't get this piece.
Their doctor doesn't understand immunology and they're lost here.
So their doctor is, well, we'll try catscloth for a while and it makes them feel better for a period of time and then they absolutely crash.
Well, we're going to try this. We're going to try this new, or we're going to try this, the Chinese, or we're going to try this.
And all of them are TH1 stimulators, so it'll make them feel better for a little bit sometimes, sometimes it'll just cause them to crash right away.
And then they'll eventually crash because you'll start just, you might help kill the Lyme, but you are going to kill your old tissue.
So you're never going to win that battle, so you cannot treat a person.
That's in phase 3 autoimmune Lyme with immune stimulants.
You have to kill it another way.
So that's where, well, should I just go a long term antibiotics? Well, that's a possibility.
But there's so much damaging effects of that. I don't ever suggest that.
No, it's a possibility. Can you use things like MMS? We'll talk about this in detail later.
Or anything that's a NUDTH1 stimulant, yes, you have to. So we test people out.
So we're very specific when we take on a chronic Lyme patient.
What is it that is going to work for that patient? Quite honestly, probably half of our autoimmune Lyme patients are on nothing.
So MMS is a supplement that might work. There's other protocols that might work. We use energy medicine.
So that is a big piece of our protocol that somebody is a TH1 dominant biotoxin, Lyme or mold or something else.
You can't use TH1 stimulants. So we use energy medicine in our office. The machine that we use is the true rife.
So the true rife, there's other rife machines out there, but the true rife I found to be the best.
That's what I like the best. I've been doing the rife machine for years and years. And that's my favorite type of rife machine.
So that's what we use. And we'll get into that. What the rife machine is a further discussion later.
But you have to kill it directly without stimulating the immune response.
We also use different brain therapies because, well, we found in most Lyme patients, in most autoimmune Lyme patients, they're developed antibodies against their own different brain cells.
And we see that most of these people suffer from brain fog and symptoms of neurological disabilities.
So in most situations, their immune system is fired against what are called your glial cells.
Two main different types of cells in your brain, the neurons that carry information, and the glial cells that do less information carry it in more support to the neurons.
There's a lot of things that they do sell that they do do, but these glial cells are separated in different types of glial cells.
And there's usually an inflammation attack on the glial cells. That's exactly what's taking place with MS and ALS.
Okay, so the take home of this, again, is treat acute phase line with endominex as soon as possible.
If you know that you're not yet in the autoimmune phase, you may try to use immune stimulants.
If you use immune stimulants, in the use of immune stimulants, that solves your problem.
Or it makes you worse, makes you feel worse, and after a period of time, you are most likely in the autoimmune phase.
Or if your disease process is quite aggressive, you're probably in the autoimmune phase.
Or if you have taken TH1 stimulants, and they make you feel worse, you're probably in the autoimmune phase.
That's one of the ways that you can kind of tell at home if you're in the autoimmune phase.
I take garlic and I feel horrible, then you're in the autoimmune phase.
I might make you feel better for a little bit, but you just never seem to get better.
So if you are in phase 3, autoimmune line, feel free to call our office, find somebody who really understands autoimmune disease and knows how to treat it.
Alright, I hope you learned a lot. If this is all review, that's great. If this is all due to you, listen to it a couple times.
Dr. Cutters, I'll talk to you soon.